well let's bring up this story we got
from timcast.com youtube and twitter
delete joe rogan's interview with
vaccine inventor dr malone the interview
regarding covet vaccines and mandates
was removed days after robert malone's
twitter was also suspended
there uh so i i don't think it was
posted by uh joe rogan though do you
guys know who uploaded this uh it was
malone himself right well when peter
mccullough was on he uploaded the full
interview on his youtube channel and
youtube took that video down so i don't
know if robert malone uploaded it on his
youtube channel
had already been uh
kicked off of twitter by time he went on
twitter but as far as the youtube video
the youtube video was uploaded in full
and then it was taken down so let me
tell you check this out so when this
when this episode on the of the joe
rogan experience dropped with dr malone
naturally it was getting huge huge uh
buzz everybody was talking about it they
just banned this guy and so i opened
spotify
normally when i open spotify it's like
the joe rogan experience front and
center trying to advertise it there was
nothing so i scroll around and i'm like
all right i'll hit podcasts i hit
podcast nothing and then i'm like
where's joe rogan
i couldn't find him
i was at first i was just trying to
search through like okay podcast okay
comedy nothing entertainment nothing
news
what
every time i used to open that before it
was like front and center watch joe
rogan so then i just had to manually
search joe rogan experience found it
went into his show profile found it and
played it that may be nothing
maybe the spotify algorithm was like tim
we don't think you actually want to
listen to joe rogan even though it's
like the only thing you listen to on
spotify so we're not gonna suggest it to
you right now but then i started seeing
videos pop up someone posted a video
where they were trying they were playing
a bunch of podcasts on spotify they even
played tim cast irl and then when they
opened up joe rogan with malone it
wouldn't load and he was like i can't
get it to play i don't understand
so i don't know if there is you know
some some you know something going on
maybe not but i got i just gotta
every time there's an accident or a
mistake it's or coincides whatever
it's only ever affecting this kind of
thing
when when people get banned oh it's a
mistake we didn't mean to ban you oh
yeah but how often is the our left
establishment people getting banned yeah
when that happens i just scream
illuminati
but again
it's also important not to jump to
conclusions but but it's also
there's so many coincidences that always
work in the favor of very powerful
people how do you draw the line here i
mean there also was a lot of internal
fighting between some spotify staff
members and joe rogan is there a
deliberate effort to undermine him maybe
we don't know but but the fact is like
these interviews the peter mccullough
tens of millions of peop millions of
people have been downloading it i think
i think last week it was 40 million
people downloaded the peter mccullough
interview how do you know how do you
know um those are the some of the
numbers
i think they released the the stats on
the the was 40 million on the malone one
last week no this was uh no this is
peter mccullough
this is the number that i saw shared
around by a lot of individuals uh 40
million for me peter mccullough last
week those those videos are still up
they're still gaining a lot of views
robert malone i don't know the exact
numbers um and and again we're talking
about it it's not unlikely it's very
likely especially with all the news and
buzz look we've seen all of these
stories about spotify going after like
spotify employees demanding joe rogan be
like banned or removed and they won't do
it
so
is is it is it absurd then to think that
these employees have just you know put
their thumb on the scale a little bit
i'll put it this way
does there need to be a concerted effort
to go after joe's uh content through
infrastructure on spotify no there
doesn't there just needs to be like a
dude he's sitting in his office and
they're like hey we need you to you know
update that form you know internally to
make sure you know the joe rogan show is
going to publish on time he goes oh okay
i'll get to it and then he laughs pulls
out his phones and starts playing you
know yeah
angry well did you guys see today that
there was it was announced that uh
random house will not be publishing a
collection of norman mailer
because one of their junior employees
complained about one of his essays that
they thought was racially insensitive
and of course this guy was writing in
the 60s
a gonzo journalist writing all kinds of
things he was mostly a left left-leaning
guy left-wing guy
but that's kind of what it takes in a
lot of these situations now is that you
have these large firms they have
employee revolts and it could be a very
small employee revolt and they have to
do something to appease them right in
this case they canceled the entire book
one of the most famous kind of 60s gonzo
journalists
and i think they actually informed his
family like his surviving family they
wouldn't be publishing the book one of
the largest publishers but this is
happening all over the place i mean
netflix had an internal revolt over dave
chappelle now we learned at the end of
the day it was just a tiny number of
employees right it was a few dozen who
walked out is a massive company and yet
the company had to go through like you
know crisis mode internally i you know i
from what i understand it was quite
intense uh within that environment
because i think that unfortunately in a
lot of these environments they are not
um
you know they've inverted the the
leadership it's it's kind of ruled by
the angry or fearful minority right it's
not that the ceo tells the junior
staffer hey we're we're a company about
you know putting out these products that
people want to watch and want to see and
you don't have a veto over them but they
won't tell them that i feel like with
youtube and twitter facebook etc
they got the opposite message from uncle
ben dying you know you guys know uncle
benny said you know he's like with great
power comes great responsibility and
peter's like go be you from now on uh so
you know facebook was like we have all
of this power but we'll be damned if we
want to take responsibility for anything
that's facebook twitter youtube it's all
of silicon valley what they don't first
of all there is political there's a
political agenda
for sure and those elements exist but
there's also cowardice in these
companies and when it comes to a lot of
the covid policy i think for the most
part it is fear of liability and there's
no liability when you're like hey man
look it's just what fauci said of the
world health organization
so if you get someone like dr malone
who's like for the most part a lone
voice
and he's saying things they're like
someone's going to sue us and that's you
can look at a lot of their policies fear
of liability so what they're basically
saying is if we just ban everybody who
dissents from like the official
narrative you can't hold us responsible
but they are the public space these
debates need to happen they are banning
dissenting scientific voices and i'll
show you this we have this from the
atlantic a smear piece and dr malone but
it does say it effectively says that dr
malone invented mrna technology they say
his two studies from night was in 1989
demonstrating how rna could be delivered
into cells using lipids
which uh which are basically tiny globs
of fet which could be used as a vaccine
or a vaccine delivery method these
studies indeed represent seminal work in
the field of gene transfer according to
ryan verbik a postdoctoral fellow at
ghent university in belgium and the lead
author of a 2019 history of mrna vaccine
development indeed malone studies are
the first two references in verbiak's
paper out of 224 in total so whether or
not you want to say he invented mrna
i'll put it this way if like the first
ever in inception of mr technology comes
from this one dude or his team then yeah
isn't that inventing something it
doesn't mean he invented the core
products it doesn't mean he made fl like
you know thomas edison invented the
light bulb they say did he invent the
fluorescent light bulb
no
but you still say invented the light
bulb right they're trying to make it
seem like he's got no grounds to
communicate they're lying they're
claiming he's not an expert there there
are these these government you know
funded scientists saying things like he
just played a minor role and has nothing
but
is he a phd
is he a doctor who specializes in
vaccines has he worked with the
government this regard okay then why are
we not allowed to hear what he has to
say
absolutely and i don't think big tech is
worried about lawsuits because what were
you gonna sue people for this scientist
provided some scientific data get him
sue him they can't do that and and if if
anything the information being provided
here adds context and information and
allows people to have informed consent
one of the things that dr robert malone
brought up that i thought was was very
instrumental here he didn't only talk
about the profit incentives of pfizer
here he also talked about bigger
institutions financial institutions like
blackrock he talked about the big
financial systems that have a lot of
egregious power that along with big tech
are working in unison to stifle out any
kind of questioning of their product
that they're trying to get you to take
that is a scary situation because you're
giving people god-like power and
authority when you're able to censor
information from the general public that
is scary that is terrifying and if
everyone
everyone should know about this and i
think this is why we're seeing such a
huge scramble of people be like hey this
is absolutely terrifying i need to move
over get away to a totally different
platform where i could actually listen
to another side of the story here which
is absolutely critically important i
feel like joe rogan's viewership is is
more now than when it was when he was on
youtube yeah i was wondering you know in
in question the larger move from youtube
to to spotify and i think if he's able
to have a better closer relationship
with spotify which it looks like he has
he's able to get get away with a lot
more because if he was still on youtube
youtube would have taken the videos down
youtube is already taking the videos
down so so this is one of the ways that
he still was able to position himself in
a way where these videos are getting
tens of millions of downloads and views
but they can't be taken down by youtube
this is i think one of the
points of leverage that
rogan would have over spotify spotify is
a much smaller company than google right
much smaller company than than uh what
alphabet or youtube can provide
um meaning that he's a much bigger asset
to spotify right i mean they they paid
100 million dollars to bring him over i
think what was the deal that was what
that was what uh i think wall street
general reported
but you never know because it could be
like over 10 years you know what i mean
sure i doubt it's that long
but the idea is that he's going to be
he's going to be a lot of revenue for
them as well right absolutely meaning
that
you know whatever pressures they have
within the company whatever pressures
they get externally from news media
whatever pressures they get externally
from government
if he's making them money and they have
their own infrastructure he has a point
of leverage over them and i think that
point of leverage is greater than what
he would have had over youtube given
this to the relative sizes of the
companies i saw this story
about a guy whose muscles are turning to
bone you ever hear about that stuff that
disorder huh you've heard about that no
i haven't where it's like um so normally
when you exercise your muscles the
proteins will break down and then your
body replaces it with you know proteins
and it grows stronger or whatever i'm
gonna i can't tell you exactly how it
works but um
apparently there are some people that
when the muscle breaks it's replaced
with calcium and just starts turning to
bone
that's kind of how i feel things are
going right now over time when somebody
like ages out or retires or moves on
from a position it gets replaced by an
an ideologue an immovable object that
creates rigidity and structural damage
that's why you we're at the point now
where you've got like spotify big
company probably has a lot of money to
lose a lot of money to make but you get
a small portion of individuals who
appear
when a certain position opens up or when
a certain position you know someone
moves on from it the woke millennial
types or whatever gen z types come in
and then just that one person it's like
bone in your muscle all of a sudden
you're struggling to move you can't
function properly and the system just
starts collapsing and failing
i saw that story i was like it kind of
feels like what's happening to our
society you know at a certain point that
they may just put a feeding tube in the
mouth of our culture and that the
government will just start subsidizing
and funding things out of fear of
collapse and economic failure and then
we're and then we're doomed and then
they'll give them a whole bunch of
fentanyl but that's my own personal
perspective but you made a very good
point because youtube could afford to
lose rogan spotify can't they invested
into him and i'll be honest when rogan
first moved on to spotify i was like
there's no way i'm downloading another
app i'm not doing this um you know i'll
look at the small clips that that he
releases but but with the debates with
the people that rogan had on robert
kennedy jr dr peter mccullough uh dr
robert malone having these important
conversations i can't miss it i had to
download the app i had to i had to sign
up for an account and and i had to
listen to it because it was the only way
i could and it's not just me it's a lot
of disenfranchised people who are asking
some serious questions that the
government can't answer right now as the
government has been caught time and time
again lying putting their foot in their
mouth and absolutely not telling the
people the truth it's very evident right
now especially with cases surging that
all of their plans everything they did
hasn't hasn't worked at all so people
are left with some serious questions
rogan is helping those questions be
answered by presenting so much data and
information and letting them decide what
actions and moves to make for themselves
with informed consent like they should
have had from the very beginning thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast if you want to
watch live you can check out this
channel monday through friday at 8 00 pm
and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you